Matthew you were really unrecognizable
in this phone you went from 170 pounds
to 217 pounds act on what 50 pounds of
this role 47 47 what was your daily like
intake of food like it was fun to say
make it a double extra cheese mayonnaise
and bacon for breakfast on the burger
and then for lunch just sipping a little
beer with with burgers or whatever
slowly you know it worked as far as
exercising cuz I didn't you can walk to
this I wouldn't take the stairs to the
second floor oh my calm after six months
of doing it I wasn't tired of it okay
i'm gonna say it's kind of stopped but I
was not tired were you worried that you
couldn't bounce back as you clearly
bounce back people around me are more
concerned going you're older now it
doesn't you don't not gonna be able to
take it off another now we'll work it
out and it did work out it took a while
it took six months to get it off as well
when I first came to see Matthew I had
heard that he you know that he looked a
little different yeah he had a shaved
head he gained 45 pounds and I was so
relieved because I think if I had met
dislike just you know big kind of this
specimen that he is I would have been
really intimidated and and instead
here's this dude that I just felt
totally comfortable what fantastic I saw
them tires transformation I we got to
Thailand he was already on its way but
not completely there the first day of
shooting what it wouldn't he showed up
completely transformed to kenny wills it
was hilarious it was so good I'm like I
know because I he had completely changed
you know I mean the way he talked and
the way he moved to me because it really
changes everything you know he was he
was living in a different body and and
there was that fun he's had a lot of fun
okay look we gotta go
Oh
you
you